and great to see you all here I would
like to speak briefly about the context
the business context of some of these
analysis tools and project examples that
you've talked that already we heard
about
so one of the challenges in
bioinformatics in general
is that bioinformatics seems to be
detached from practical challenges and
problems so the hackathon is an
opportunity to connect biotechnology or
where the data is getting generated and
what to do with that data to
bioinformatics where we focus on
analysis approaches and insights from
data with real world problems and these
are defined in business terms
so as someone who has started several
different companies in the past it has a
lot of experience and success and
failure in a lot of these companies I
know that there are several important
things to think about as you approach
this hackathon
so the first one is what problem are we
solving and how are we solving this
problem
the second one is what does the solution
really look like and who is going to use
that solution and then what is the
business value proposition how does this
solve a business problem that someone is
willing to pay for
so the objective of the hackathon is to
connect these together and allow student
teams or research teams to try and
propose some of these problems and face
the uh kind of real world challenges and
opportunities that the microbiome has
produced
so one important aspect of this is
really how to narrow down the many
different opportunities that are out
there that align with your interests and
have the potential to be interesting to
investors users or companies that you
might work with or for
so as someone who maybe comes from a
biotechnology
bioinformatics or a research background
you might be thinking how can I leverage
some of my understanding of this field
and what the potential of the microbiome
holds to really showcase my skills and
understanding of how this could work in
a very very practical way and so this is
going to be
critical to understand Beyond just kind
of the technical things that we've
already heard about and focused on what
does this solution really look like
so the first subject that you will have
to decide is what problem will you solve
and we separated this hackathon into
three specific problems the first one is
gut microbiome and again we are focused
on pre-clinical uh challenges and
problems so the reason for that is
because when you start going to clinical
problems there's all kinds of ethical as
as well as regulatory issues that we
just don't have the time to address so
this hackathon is going to be focused on
pre-clinical opportunities so what are
some opportunities with microbiome for
health and wellness the immediate thing
that comes to mind of course is obesity
uh General kind of Health and Wellness
but it becomes a lot more detailed as
you start looking at the data so what we
will do for that particular challenge is
bring you experts that have seen
multiple companies that are trying to
innovate in that space and connect
insights from microbiome studies to
specific challenges like obesity or
pre-clinical conditions like
pre-diabetic you know patients and and
people who experience negative results
of obesity to try and solve them with
different types of interventions and
we'll talk about what opportunities are
there what other companies are trying to
do how you might differentiate and what
is the real value proposition for some
company or idea or a product that wants
to kind of you know disrupt the market
and do something different
the second field
is related to Beauty aging and skin
microbiome so the skin microbiome is
very different from the gut microbiome
and that leads to specific methods of
sequencing data preparation analysis
Etc and so what we will do is we will
curate several examples that during the
month of November we will actually
share some insights from and we will
bring some experts who are actively
pursuing this opportunity with skin
microbiome and have identified some
interesting Trends and maybe special
opportunities that you could focus on as
well
the third one
is related to the general topic of
femtech so femtech refers to
um you know technology that can help
address issues like pregnancy healthy
pregnancy healthy birth uh conception
and things like that and so what is
important there is that you know you
need to understand uh how real data can
inform us about these things in general
as a research problem but then also how
can we take insights from these research
questions and turn them into practical
actual tools or products that people
will use so one example of a product
could be a recommendation engine and so
we will spend some time speaking about
what is a recommendation engine how can
we use insights from microbiome data
analysis and Link it to other types of
information like diet physical activity
genetic background and environment
so what's important is to be able to use
some kind of an analytical approaches to
be able to categorize different types of
interventions suggest combination of
steps that need to be taken and also to
monitor progression we will also talk
about who is your audience and the
importance of understanding your
audience and how they view a potential
product so here what's going to be
important is to think of you know the
age range the background maybe in terms
of how where people work what do they
know what is their education level and
to be able to analyze that data and come
up with real clear understanding of what
is the market that you're trying to
approach with your solution
so we'll talk about
um some of the challenges and
opportunities that existing companies on
the market have faced for example a lot
of the companies that are already making
microbiome testing available on the
market are facing a problem of
knowledge and understanding of what the
microbiome can do for them cost of
sequencing and cost of these tests so
how much people are willing to pay for
some of these tests or even the their
ability to follow the instructions that
you know maybe these tests will
recommend right purchase additional Pro
and prebiotics change their dietary
habits Etc
so then we'll talk about what is the
product right what really could you
um
propose
as your ultimate solution and that can
fall into several different categories
so it can fall into the category of a
real physical product for example a pre
or a probiotic that could be a pill that
could be a cream uh you know it could be
some kind of a marketable product that
is physical and then you face additional
challenges right where are you going to
Source those specific
interventions how are they going to be
packaged who are they going to be sold
through Etc
uh maybe you're thinking of a product
idea that is an application uh that the
users will use on their smart watch or
their iPhone or you know some kind of a
mobile device
um that could be an option as well and
there you need to think about well what
exactly is it going to do where's the
data going to come from and what kinds
of insights are going to be made
available
and then you could also be might be
thinking about a product that is not for
a customer it's maybe for a company so a
company will need a very different type
of insight compared to a user right so
instead of an individual and their
recommendations they might want to look
at comparison between multiple
individuals or multiple types of
products or multiple types of challenges
so really it's a platform kind of an
idea foreign
we will talk about how to define your
competition in terms of the value chain
for example there are many different
microbiome testing kits on the market
how are they different from each other
why do each one of them uh you know
claim that they are the most advanced or
the most comprehensive how do we
actually know if they're more advanced
or more comprehensive and then based on
their pricing how can we identify who is
going after the low pricing strategy
who's going after the high and premium
kind of a product strategy and how can
you position yourself and differentiate
sufficiently from this competition to
offer something new different and
valuable to your target market we'll
also talk about some of the trends in
the market which areas have been tried
which areas remain to be tried and what
is successful what is not successful
what is growing what is kind of
diminishing what are some of these
trends that are important to look at
finally we will talk about how your
solution can capture the market so as a
whole we know that the market is growing
at a fairly rapid Pace at the same time
we know that investors are becoming
concerned with new companies just
proposing kind of marketing campaigns of
the same Solutions focused on just
pricing differences so really there is
going to be a challenge not only to
develop an idea about the product but
also Define how can this product be
introduced now of course this is not
going to be something that you have to
figure out completely over the course of
the full hackathon the idea here is
really to
think through all of these different
stages
understanding the microbiome space from
a technology and from the value
proposition sides combining this
understanding with a practical
opportunity in one of the three areas
that we already defined and then working
with a mentor to get enough feedback
about your proposal so that you can
actually present something meaningful
and valuable at the hackathon end
so with that
that key
um kind of result from all of this is
going to be your demo and the demo is
primarily a uh presentation so the
presentation will address your
um you know insights so this must be
based on real data again we will provide
you with some examples of data but we
will also talk about other repositories
of data that you could leverage to gain
insights and so you can use either the
tools that we have described today or
your own analysis pipeline but the main
idea would be that whatever your
proposed solution is it is based on
insights that are rooted in real data
sets these data sets might not be
comprehensive they might not answer all
of the questions but there is enough
evidence that this is realistic and
important
the second will be your market research
analysis so how have you analyzed the
market itself uh the competition that is
out there how many people or companies
will be using your product and what are
some trends that are important to
understand in terms of regulatory
Frameworks uh you know opportunities for
monetization and things like that
the next point will be about product
design what is this is this a physical
product is this an application is this a
platform
um is this some kind of uh you know
report that you are spelling or that you
are proposing to develop
um and how will that be used by real
users where will they find out about it
how will they you know produce data that
will be ingested what would be the
results of that analysis what would be
the actual points at which they need to
interact maybe with support or you know
consultation or something like that so
thinking through all of those aspects of
the product so to say
the value proposition so how is this
product solving that problem that people
are willing to pay for right and what is
the alternative that maybe they have to
avoid to choose this proposal that you
have
then we'll talk about go to market
strategy are you going to advertise and
sell on Amazon are you going to develop
an app and put it on the you know um
iPhone or Android platforms are you
going to you know organize some kind of
a marketing campaign with hospitals or
Wellness Center centers you know what
exactly is your strategy and how
realistic is that strategy what needs to
happen for that to be successful and
then finally what is the business value
so what is the business value that is
being produced by using this solution
are these new insights that are somehow
valuable to companies are these
recommendations that people can use are
they going to stay with it just for you
know one time or is this going to be a
continuous value that is generated and
maybe to multiple users at the same time
so really the culmination of this
hackathon
is going to be about how you can
contextualize your understanding of
biotechnology your bioinformatics
capabilities and your uh kind of
understanding of data analysis
approaches like algorithms and user
interfaces to produce some kind of a
business value and we hope that as a
result you will showcase your ability to
think differently
um kind of understand the market and
propose real innovative solutions and
connect with experts in the field
companies as well as investors that are
ready to consider in a more serious way
some of the ideas that you might have
so with that I would like to um pass it
on to ayushi I guess to talk about the
schedule of the hackathon and the
registration